for the first time in nearly nine months
the residents of Herson woke to the
sights and sounds of a city restored to
life
[Applause]
[Music]
this is for body Square in the center
the word means freedom and with it comes
joy and laughter
it's not peace time as such but for as
long as possible they'll pretend it is
the Russian army has merely retreated to
the east side of the danipro river
easily in artillery range as they
withdrew the Russians destroyed critical
infrastructure the TV Tower
bridges over the denipro including this
one near the kakovka dam causing
significant damage to parts of the dam
wall
and satellite imagery shows the damaged
antonivsky Bridge the main Crossing from
west to east
Russia announced that it had completed
an orderly withdrawal on Friday morning
foreign
but the evidence suggests it was
anything but some units were forced to
flee across temporary pontoons under
heavy Ukrainian fire there were reports
of drownings another is said to have
been ordered to dress in civilian
clothes and Escape by any means
available
and large quantities of military
hardware weapons and Munitions were
abandoned along with reports of Russian
dead and wounded
Ukraine's president hailed a stunning
Victory
the people of her son waited they never
gave up on Ukraine they were right to
pin their hopes on Ukraine and Ukraine
always returns its own
was it for Russia it was the latest in a
series of Battlefield defeats and all
the more humiliating coming just six
weeks after her son was formally annexed
by Moscow a city that resisted the
occupation when it began on March the
second until that resistance proved
futile a city that was so recently
proclaimed Russian Forever by Vladimir
Putin
has proven itself in scenes of euphoria
that won't end anytime soon to be
Ukrainian to its core Jonah Hall Al
Jazeera
is standing by for us in Moscow but
first let's go to assadbagan crevieri in
central Ukraine and uh I said what's the
latest uh in her song City can you just
bring us up to date there
well you understand that the city is
still without electricity there's been
damaged to the infrastructure there but
the main electricity provider here has
said it will take approximately 30 days
to restore electricity we also
understand that the our humanitarian
organizations taking in food and water
for the people there remember there's
been a battle taking place and there
were accusations that the Russians were
destroying infrastructure as they
withdrew now as you heard from that
report the situation Still Remains the
Same pretty much in terms of the damage
to the antonovsky bridge and kakova Dam
and the ukrainians will want to look at
that but also the Russians have
announced a new temporary as they call
it uh capital for the Horizon region
they're saying they're moving that
Johanna chesk they're saying that it was
temporary I assume because they feel
they will retake this land but there is
that river between Ukrainian troops and
Russian troops but they're still within
Striking Distance the Russians are able
to use the artilleries to still hit
croissant but at least for now as as you
saw in that report people are happy and
they've been welcoming Ukrainian troops
okay acid bake for us in creveury thank
you very much for that update
well let's go to Muhammad Val who is in
Moscow for us and as we saw there
Muhammad ukrainians celebrating a major
victory have there been any comments so
far from the Russian leadership
right the comment that we have today is
from Dimitri medveda former president of
Russia and also he's the second most
powerful man in the country as he is the
vice chairman of the uh of the of the
vice chairman of the National Security
Council which is presided by Putin
himself
basically he said that in this in the
difficult circumstances in the difficult
in front of these difficult military
decisions so that's a reference and
indirect mention of what happened in
Harrison the withdrawal of the Russian
troops he did not mention herzan he did
not mention Ukraine but he used those
words saying that we have to remember
what happened this year the achievements
of the Russian Federation this year
talking about a long tally of results
including the protection of the Russian
citizens I think that's an allusion to
the people of donetskan lugarsk and the
other areas which Russia claim to be uh
to be a Russian the protection of those
citizens and the restoration of a
Russian land also a reference to the
annexation of those territories that
Russia has put under its control this
year
he said Russia is fighting alone against
NATO and the combined Western might in
order to create a more just and more
fair International order and that's a
task a mission that only Russia can do
only Russia can can destroy such a
powerful enemy and create such a such a
just world I'm paraphrasing his words
here so he he went on talking about the
grand scheme that is ahead of this
mission for Russia
alluding to the to the necessity for the
Russians not to look at at temporary
situations and saying that Russia is
looking for safety for its citizens
Russia is trying to create a just world
and Russia has not used its might it
hasn't used all its arsenals and it is
choosing carefully where to strike
trying to avoid places where there are
concentrations of civilians still I'm
paraphrasing what he said
but everything has its time and the
things will happen things that the
Russian's desire will happen when they
re when they unite when they maintain
the unit their unity and they when they
work hard for those results okay
Mohammed Val for us in Moscow thank you
very much for that update